ce n'est pas encore le retour à la
normale méonier presque moscou commence
à assouplir les restrictions antico vide
après deux mois de fermeture les musées
les bibliothèques les sites culturels
rouvrent leurs portes aux moscovites toi
les statuts ne s'ennuieront plus dans
les salles vides et pourront reprendre
leur dialogue avec les visiteurs même si
les musées ne sont autorisés à
accueillir qu'à 50% de leurs capacités
c'est très dur parce que j'aime beaucoup
les musées c'est difficile de réaliser
toutes les difficultés que le musée
pouchkine a traversé pour survivre
pendant cette période
which is more cela nous a manqué et nous
avons attendu très longtemps voulait
enfin sortir quelque part et l'ouverture
des musées c'est magnifique c'est une
très bonne nouvelle et china open gt à
l'aube le moisi bien sûr il est très
difficile de ne pas éprouver des
émotions des émotions intenses
oui on peut visiter les musées en ligne
mais bien sûr c'est très différent ce
qui sera dit en toute circonstance il
faut trouver au moins quelque chose de
bien
transformer des citrons en limonade en
l'occurrence je voudrais dire que le
musée même étant isolé de ses visiteurs
a continué quand même de fonctionner ont
préparé ce futur projet ou plutôt le
projet qui est maintenant en cours
le travail est en train d'être mené il
s'agit de l'exposition pour paris des
oeuvres collectées par les morozov
cette pause forcée n'a rien détruit au
contraire le musée manqué à ses
visiteurs et ils vont peut-être nous
apprécier davantage et
moi je bosse higuita les mesures
d'assouplissement concerne également les
théâtres les salles de concerts qui
pourront désormais accueillir des
spectateurs non à 25% mais à 50% de
leurs capacités
et bonne nouvelle pour les parents
épuisés par leur enfant les restrictions
sont levés pour les établissements de
loisirs pour l'enfant et les
établissements sportifs la propagation
actuelle de l'infection à coronavirus
nous donnent des raisons de faire preuve
d'un optimisme prudent
au cours de la dernière semaine entre
2000 et 4000 nouveaux cas d'infection
ont été détectés quotidiennement ce qui
est nettement moins qu'à la fin du mois
de décembre les taux de vaccination ont
considérablement augmenté
plus de deux cent vingt mille habitants
de moscou ont déjà reçu une protection
fiable contre le virus dans cette
situation nous pouvons nous permettre
d'assouplir considérablement les
restrictions existantes
on peut partager l'optimisme du merbau
mousse courront non mais au moins à la
tante de la fin de la pandémie sera ou
un de l'heureuse en compagnie de renoir